so the next story today
um who in
you know I'm not gonna lie guys I don't
know much about Putin when it comes to
Russian history
you know I don't I don't know a ton when
it comes to what's going on in Ukraine
I'm not like your Ukraine Russia expert
but put it has really done some based
[__] lately and you guys already know my
opinion I think we should ban porn
only fans birth control I would just
take it all away in Pearl's world but we
don't live in Pearl's world but in
Putin's world he actually agrees with me
on one of these things so who in band
Only fan in Russia that man woke up and
chose violence he said I I'm not in my
country not today and you know I think
what we're going to continue to see is
other countries fighting back against
this leftist propaganda as you guys know
there are certain countries in Africa
that have said no to passing gay
marriage laws and it's unfortunate
because in the U.S we really have not
seen a hard push back on a lot of this
leftist Marxist ideology this propaganda
that they're pushing in schools this
propaganda that they're pushing at home
and when you think about it guys men
really cannot avoid this stuff
how is a guy a God-fearing guy supposed
to operate in our society without being
bombarded with naked women you know he
opens his phone and what's on there a
bunch of naked women he goes outside and
in Vegas guys I just got back from Vegas
these chicks these chicks put stickers
on their boobs and that's it
so he goes outside the women are half
naked and you know only fans is
unfortunate because it really
I don't want to say takes advantage
because each person makes their own
decision but you know most men don't
have sexual access so really only 20 30
at most 50 percent of men are really
getting laid like that so most men are
really lonely most men are not having
sex so it leaves the bottom 50 to
roughly 80 percent of men sexless and
you know one of the you know
quote-unquote Solutions we've brought in
is not to you know pass policies that
don't incentivize promiscuity
um instead
we reward the promiscuity with only fans
and women are making millions of dollars
being a [__] and you know I I started
off really libertarian
and you know I've never been like crazy
political one way or the other but
I started off as more of a Libertarian I
would say but the older I get the more I
see I do think societies should ban
things that are harmful to the society
as a whole like you know you see the
divorce rate Spike after the
implementation of birth control and no
fault divorce and are those are those
two policies really good for society is
it good for society when one out of
three women has an STD is it good for
society when one out of three women has
gotten an abortion you know and
when we're starting to get to the point
where we're not even at a replacement
population rate
um we beg the question when do lawmakers
step in and maybe take away some of
these freedoms like you know it's not
like we're free
you can't kill somebody you can't rob a
store so this idea that we should be
free to just do anything I think is
silly and you could argue that only fans
is predatory on sexless men you know
maybe I wouldn't go that far because
people make their own decisions but
really men cannot avoid like a guy that
wants to be a Christian guy wait till
he's married and not have women and not
be overcome by lust really is [__] out
of luck in the west and it's really
unfortunate because we really see
Society like degrading before our eyes
we see all of these only fans workers
having kids and their kids having these
like crazy mental health problems like
how many Clips have we seen of these
chicks like wanting to get on a plane
and just like screaming or people
fighting in the street and it's so crazy
I was walking around London and like
even today I was taking my dog for a
walk and I just saw these two people
like screaming at each other and I I
just couldn't help but think like
you know I I didn't live in London but
I'll just say even in you know I was
just in Vegas and Like I go to a lot of
different cities the cities weren't
always like this you know the Homeless
Problem wasn't always this bad and the
homeless were a lot more like respectful
it wasn't like you know I mean they
would kind of like go under a bridge
they wouldn't be like sleeping in broad
daylight they wouldn't really be like
like following you like I was in Vegas
the other day and I'm sitting okay I'm
sitting on this bench
and freaking
this homeless guy sits next to me and
there's broken glass on the bench and
it's like a concrete one and then he
says I'm not gonna stab you with the
glass and me I'm not about to you know I
mean he said he wouldn't so I was like
all right but I'm not about to sit and
find out you know what I mean I'm like I
am out of here I just start like light
jogging and
I I had to get the hell out of there and
I just kept thinking I'm like this
really wouldn't have happened like 20 30
even like five ten years ago and it
really gets you thinking like every big
problem in society is rooted to single
mother homes the criminals are from
single mother homes the mental
institutions are filled with people from
single mother homes
um the kids that drop out of school run
away from home single mother homes I I
guarantee the only fans workers if we
took a poll single mother homes there's
no problem in society that is not
encouraged and pushed by women by single
mother homes and really I believe that
there's a natural order in the world and
that it should go God men women children
and I really think evil happens when we
mess up the natural order of the world
so you know when men don't follow God
they follow Satan and they commit a
genocide right you know there's women
women that hit the age of 22 never
having had a positive relationship with
a guy in their life and when that
becomes common in a society I I really
think that's when you see an increase in
mental health problems crime and I
personally think that the only way
um that we can fix this is to stop
having policies that reward bad behavior
only fans rewards bad behavior the
government rewards bad behavior
at times men reward bad behavior and I
just think when we have this Society
where women can do whatever they want in
a face zero consequence
um you know we're in a tricky dangerous
place so let me know what you guys think
in the comments um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell and I will talk to you
guys next time